hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar isolation and expansion of
mesenchymal stromal or stem cells for
translational and clinical research
I'm Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes to leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Milton e biotech
Milton E biotech is a global provider of
products and services that advanced
biomedical research and cellular therapy
the company's innovative tools support
research at every level from basic
research to translational research to
clinical application this integrated
portfolio enables scientists and
clinicians to obtain analyze and utilize
the cell the company also offers
comprehensive scientific support
consultation and expert training to
learn more about Milton e biotech visit
wwl-tv biotech com let's get started you
can post questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the drop-down box located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Katherine God
hearts a teen coordinator and project
manager of the Rd stem cell and
regenerative medicine group at Milton E
biotech Katherine joins Milton E by
texe R&D department in 2001 she received
a bachelor's degree from the university
of mainz
in germany and finished her thesis on
characterization of endothelial
progenitor cells at milton e biotech
catherine has long-term experience on
separation technologies development of
cell culture media and adaptation of
separation and cultivation processes
into clinical scale closed systems for
mesenchymal stem cells
Catherine Goddard's will now begin her
presentation hello everybody thank you
Judy for this nice introduction to the
Smitty biotech webinar which is on the
isolation and expansion of mesenchymal
stem cells for translational and
clinical research so this is you know
the presentation of our disclaimer we
are Purdue and providing several
research reagents and some of them are
fda-approved so for more information you
can here find a lot of interesting
interesting information so the agenda
for today is depicted here so first I
would like to give you some interesting
in facts about military biotech
furthermore then we come to our topic
so clinical scale expansion of MSC's I
would like to introduce our theorem and
Zeno free cultivation solution and also
our new cleaning max prodigy at your in
cell culture system I will end our my
presentation with a brief summary
so first here I will come now to some
interesting facts so Milton E biotech
was founded in 1989 and now we have a
number of employees so up to 2,500
people are working for Milton E biotech
worldwide we are more for more than 44
nations I'm part of the R&D department
so this group is quite big so 20% of all
the employees are working in our R&D
department and we have worked on about
20,000 scientific publications up to now
describing a lot of interesting worked
in all all our different fields we are
working the product portfolio is also
quite bright so more than 15,000
products are available and a lot of our
products are in the cell therapy field
so clinical field more than 55,000 cell
therapy our therapies were produced with
multi biotech products about 2,500
patients are treated up to now up to now
per year with with the use of our
technology our products are available in
28 countries all over the world and we
have 7300 which are distributed by
several distributor
so our aim is to make it easy to have
some research on one hand and go into
the clinic later on so from bench to
bedside this is what we would like to do
and so in this case we are providing
sample preparation reagents reagent for
settle isolation activation and
expanding of course and after expansion
cells can be analyzed using our analysis
product and also the flow cytometer if
the work from research goes more and
more into pre clinic or into the clinic
we make it quite easy with our
bench-to-bedside aim and therefore here
we have several products which are very
similar in research or in clinic so for
example the second media are very
similar so it's very easy to try to
cultivate cells
afterwards for clinical applications
cell analysis and also cell processing
with the prodigy so now I'd like to
point out challenges and clinical scale
expansion of MSDS so here briefly
there's the MSE workflow which we are
following or a number of people in the
MSE field are following so first we
start with a starting material different
kind of tissues I used bone marrow
adipose tissue umbilical cord MSDS have
been isolated by plastic adherents and
expanded depending on the application
you are following so on the one hand of
course small-scale research applications
are used and also a lot of clinical
application small-scale when you think
about how to look at settings or
large-scale expansions for any kind of
allergenic lean
settings after expansion in most cases
says a cryopreserved and quality control
um so this workflow of course beers a
lot of challenges and there's a nice and
informative survey from Waghmare a wreck
magnet on corn trends and future
developments in MSE research and this
survey was available to all numbers of
the recommended community and was
completely completed by scientists
students technicians group leaders from
both academia and from the technology
and medical device companies so here it
comes out that the biggest challenges
were or were identified in transferring
processes to GMP and also to maintain
the phenotype and the function of MSE
what's needed to overcome these
challenges when working with MS es and
here also the survey gave some nice
feedback so most important for people in
the field are improved cell culture
product better methods of expansion
people need help in complying with GMP
regulations and also it is quite
important to have integrated closed
systems so now I'd like to show you how
Milton E biotech with our product
portfolio in the MSC fear tries to meet
these challenges and tries to improve
the workflow for our customers in this
field so coming now first to the second
media to the Xenu and serum-free fair
culture media for a long time we are
providing FCS containing set culture
media now but afterward the field more
and more goes into clinic
xeno free media are more and more
important and coming in to the focus so
therefore we are providing vino and film
free media now so there is a stem
max/msp
abandon media kit except which is a
research grade media it's provided in
five hundred milliliter bottles with a
corresponding supplement of course it's
Pino and serum free the whole
formulation no substrate for pre coating
of circuitry weathers is required so
this is quite unique point here and
because in a lot of other cases from
commercial available media a substrate
is necessary so in this case it's not
also when you start with primary tissue
and also there is no additional
supplement growth factors or any other
kind of theorem necessary to start your
MSC cultivation process and now if you
would like to go more into
Clinic focus more on clinical
preclinical work we are providing the
MSE Bruijn p medium which really shows
the same formulation the same benefits
like the stem Maximus expanding media
except only the reagents or the raw
material are regulated to a higher grade
to meet the GMP standards so this media
the MSC Bru media comes in back so in
500 milliliter or 2 litre bags is fin
its phenol red free we are also
providing corresponding supplements
which are aseptically filled and the
whole formulation as I said is in
compliance with relevant GMP guidelines
during the development we followed the
recommendations of USP 10:43 on
ancillary materials so this medium is
quite a nice solution to start GMP
compliant work and to go further into
the clinic
so now I'd like to show you some
important facts regarding our medium
with the perspective of performance so
the stem acts MSE XF and MSE Bruijn P
media support colony formation
starting with primary tissue the here on
this slide you can see the number of
colonies per well in bars and the dots
is are depicting the cell number pavel
so we have compared here our ms e xf
medium and the MS Ebru medium with a
standard used homebrew alpha mem or dmem
with plate lighter than FCS and
furthermore we have compared to
competitors where of course here in this
case you really have to add a be serum
for this first isolation of cells from
the starting material so it's not not
possible to use the competitor media
here without a B theorem there are no
colonies at all at the end in the cell
culture well so better MSC adhesion
results in a higher number of C if you
have colonies using the stem mark 6f and
the MSE bruge MP media
but of course we were also interested in
how efficient the clinical scale
isolation of MSE is using our cell
culture media again here we compared the
XF and the MSE brew medium with the DMM
and alpha mem homebrew media we use
three different donors ten milliliters
bone marrow aspirate each we cultivated
the cells until we get 200 million MSE s
which is round about a number which is
used for autologous clinical
applications and we could show you quite
nicely that just after 15 days we are
harvesting this 200 million of cells
using our media the SEM acts and the MSE
brew medium so when we use the DME mo
alpha mem containing medium this took
much longer so more than 30 days several
passages were necessary and even for the
SDS containing medium for two donors at
all we could not reach the number of
cells after 30 days so here we have some
pictures showing that we are quite fast
with our medium so just in 14 days we
are reaching the 200 million MSC s and
of course when you are faster you are
not using so much medium so the medium
consumption is also reduced from 50 to
70% which of course reduces some cost
here
but not only the set number is important
it's also important how the cells are
behaving after long-term cultivation so
in this case here we show some data
expanding MSE s from bone marrow for
about six passages in this four
different conditions and as you can see
there is a stable growth rate for the
Denmark six F and the MSE brew GMP
medium
so after expansion the MSC were analyzed
for their phenotype and their function
so in this case here we were using the
MSC phenotyping kit which is a flow
based assay to analyze cervix expression
markers the MSE phenotyping kit consists
three different positive markers CD 105
CD 73 and 390 and also some negative
marker cd14 CD 2345 and cd34 these are
all markers which were also mentioned
from the ICT consortium to be used for
MSC identification so this essay is
quite reproducible and rapid and it's a
cocktail so it's quite easy to use
furthermore it's important that MSC show
their multi lineage differentiation
potential and we have analyzed this by
using the military differentiation media
for adipocytes osteoblasts and genre
sites the pictures I here shown in the
middle and as you can see the
differentiation potential is observed
after these six passages for when you
use the MS Ebru GMP medium or stem max
medium and also we looked for a specific
function of MSDS which is related to
their immune model Ettore capacity so
here we use the t-cell suppression
inspector which is an essay to analyze
the teaser the suppression of
proliferating t-cells so to explain this
in more detail T cells T cells were
labeled with a membrane dye and then
within flow based assay after simulation
can detect the proliferation rate of
t-cells by the dilution rate of the
membrane dye and when you then spike em
SES in different concentration and
co-culture them with T cells you can
really nice detect this suppression of T
cell proliferation and this works quite
nice in all cases whether you use the MS
Ebru GMP medium or the homebrew alpha
mam and the Mme dmem cell culture media
so coming now to this new clinic max
prodigy adherent fed culture system so
here you can see again the quite complex
way of producing cells in a GMP like
manner so there are different steps
there are a number of different devices
you have to use so incubator sensitive
centrifuge you have to use microscope
and a lot of hands-on time of course
everything is done in cleanroom it's
really not easy to to go in and out
without yeah without spending a lot of
money a lot of time so it's quite
time-consuming process and our aim here
is to bring everything together in one
solution so the cleaning max prodigy as
an all-in-one solution for the complex
product manufacturing
so now if we would like to have closer
look the system looks like that so here
we have the hardware of the clinic's
prodigy platform we have an integrated
and closed system so where you can
really do a lot of automated processing
steps and for example sample preparation
density gradient centrifugation is done
within the century cooled unit which you
can see here on the right side cell
washing can be done media changed
magnetic phase separation cell
stimulation genetic modification and of
course at the end of final product
formulation
so the whole system is closed from
sample to product and this is done by
single-use disposable tubing sets the
stereo features and input ports and
there is the possibility to do sterile
wedding and a lot of cases for example
to collect I will say catch a media bag
see right to the tubing set to connect
their cultivation Wizards so everything
can be connected in a sterile way a way
they are integrated to see sample
poetry's where you easy kill easily can
take samples during the fair cultivation
process to analyze the cells between
different passages
so I mentioned the sentry code unit so
the CCU and also external culture
weathers now I'd like to introduce this
in more detail
so the Sentry code unit the CTU has got
a surface of 100 square centimeter this
can be used for the cultivation of
adherent and non adherent cells of
course for MSE this is not really a
large area so therefore our later on I
will come to the external culture
weathers but of course when you think
about starting with umbilical cord or
small tissue pieces which are
enzymatically digested then it could be
an option to use this 100 square
centimeter so to really start with a
small scale and then upscale this so
this is possible here in this CCU so
it's also possible then to have the
automated feeding and harvesting
procedure with the central unit its
temperature controlled from 4 to 38
degrees also co2 air and and to
controlled to get sufficient environment
for cell growing we have got a
microscope integrated he and the prodigy
for visual cell examination and of
course multiple input ports for
different media cytokines but of course
if you like to cultivate enlarger
surfaces which are really required for
the MSA workflow there is this really
nice possibility to connect in the
sterile well external culture results
and this gives you the opportunity for
really scalable manufacturing process
so coming now to the tubing set clothes
tubing set which is used for this
cultivation process so it's a GMP
compliant tubing set which where you
have steer our wedding possibilities as
I already said so you can connect the
circuit media of course everything else
which is also necessary so the enzymatic
digestion solution the enzymatic
stopping should solution they're
integrated bags and fabric pouches as
you can see on the in the middle of the
picture where you can yeah waving the QC
samples during the different passages
and you have the easy connection of the
external culture weather here on the
lower level of the tubing set at was
nineteen for circuit reversals we are
using here in this picture as you can
see cell specs which are available in
different sizes from one layer to layer
of five layer and at the end you can
connect three different stacks in
parallel and can process them
subsequently with a prodigy which is
also possible is to connect the climax
electroporator to this system which then
gives you the possibility for genetic
[Music]
modification of cells
so here you can see the GMP compliant
MSC expanding process how we have
developed them this process for the
cleaning max prodigy at UNC catcher
system so everything is done as you
would also do it manually so you start
with bone marrow you have the density
gradient centrifugation with which is
performed completely automated in the
device afterwards you can have is the
bone marrow mononuclear cells which are
washed in the cultivation media so that
afterwards you can directly start the
class evasion in the external circuitry
weather says I split it in this closed
system again feed it in higher or larger
surface area cultivated again up to the
number of passages which are necessary
for your process and then you can
harvest assess automatically choose
sufficient harvest mediums which you
might also use for direct application or
freezing and at the end you have your
final set product
of course this process is also adaptable
to different starting materials like
umbilical cord and adipose tissue
so here there is a nice picture which
shows the performance of our process so
we started with 30 milliliter of bone
marrow the whole process can be
processed with 30 up to 100 milliliters
of bone marrow but in this case here we
show the example of 30 milliliter we
started with the the density gradient
sentence to yield bone marrow
mononuclear cells we use the MNC Bru GMP
medium and compared them the expansion
of cells with manual process so in both
cases after 10 days such were around
about 70 to 80 percent confluent we have
as itself in the clinic max prodigy by
starting the harvesting procedure seated
themselves again and ended up then after
14 days with 400 million MSS which is
quite a high number so at the end we use
three five layer sticks in parallel
process by the cleaning max prodigy so
of course characterization of MSC is
also very important so again here we use
the MSC phenotyping kit including the
analysis for CD 3073 CD 105 and CD 90
and all markers were highly expressed as
well as the MSE the non MSE markers
which were negative on these cells so
roundabout at the end we also calculated
the time we were using and in both cases
so the manual process and the clinics
process and here the graphic on the
right side shows quite nicely that we
could reduce the hands-on time using the
prodigy for about 70 percent so this at
the end is quite interesting so because
all the hands-on time which is done in
the clear
room can be really reduced to a minimum
so coming now to the summary here we
talk about the challenges which came up
in the clinical field process the trend
is to transfer the process to GMP for
example and which is or what is really
important at the end for the people in
the field is the improvement of Sur
culture products better methods for
expansion helping in complying with GMP
and having integrated closed system and
for all these things we could show quite
nice solutions by introducing our
students in AU and Theon free cell
culture media and also to provide the
closed adherence haircutter process
using the clean Emacs prodigy
so the improve the arm see no free
medium supports efficient clinical scale
MS expansion from different tissue
sources
the new clean Emacs prodigy adherent
psychiatrist system allows MCS to
isolate and expand in an integrated
closed system and we have complete
workflow for standardized MSC
characterization isolation expand in
phenotyping and functional analysis
so thank you very much for your
attention Thank You Catherine for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Catherine godhardt will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is how many MSE cells can you
acquire from the ACC process prodigy
using 3-5 layer self Stax and is it
possible to include more cell stacks to
acquire a higher number of cells okay so
with three five layers text we can
harvest around about 400 million MSDS
which is quite a high number and of
course it's also possible to upscale the
process to six five layers tags so that
would be related to a surface of nearly
20,000 square centimetre so which is
about two square meter and we are
planning some experiments in the near
future to to test it for MSE from bone
marrow and some other tissues in the
near future thank you next question is
can you explain what are the differences
between your GMP medium and research
grade excess medium
so the formulation of the MFC expansion
media mix F and MSE Bruijn P medium is
really the same
so however these two products are
produced in different manufacturing
sites so MSE expanding media mix F is
produced in bearish clappa and the MSE
brew GMP medium is produced in our GMP
facility and tadaryl since the
production processes of these two media
slightly differ finally products have
derived a different form formats so one
supplement verses to supplement for
example so one supplement index as
medium and two supplements in the GMP
medium also the deep GMP medium is
provided in very convenient bags and
200m 500 milliliter and two liter which
makes it easier to stay and complement
completely closed environment during the
cell processing so furthermore there are
our GMP media are manufactured and
tested under quality system certified to
ezel 13485 and e2 9001 so the design of
the media follow the recommendations of
USP 10:43 and is in compliance with
relevant GMP guidelines all media are
filled using an aseptically filling line
all media undergo of string and quality
testing including functional quality
controls as well as for example
sterility testing according to the
standards of the European chemical yeah
so the GMP media we are providing
required documentation for regulatory
review of course and we are including
the certificate of analysis certificate
of origin and the product information
file
thank you the next question is can you
comment on the differences between the
ACCC process in prodigy and other
bioreactors for example quantum and can
you explain a bit more about the
benefits of the ACCC process and prodigy
compared to other bioreactors yes so
with the prodigy we have a scalable
system so as I explained there's a
central unit with 100 square centimeter
and we can upscale the cultivation area
to 9000 square centimeter or even 19th
20,000 square centimeter when we use six
five layers stacks while another
bioreactors they're fixed area therefore
not there therefore they are not able to
scale up the process so and that can be
quite not so easy when you start with
small starting volumes of materials of
example low number of bone marrow low
number of adipose tissue so therefore
it's not so flexible in an our system
everything is quite very flexible
so furthermore we do not need to code
the cell stacks for the culture while in
most cases other bioreactors so whether
you use carriers for cultivation or holo
fiber modules they need always to be
coded before you start the cultivation
whatever medium you are using so this is
quite time-consuming and this is also
quite expensive at the end yeah so in
this case there's quite a sum advantage
in our system so furthermore that the
energy gradient centrifugation process
is included and our ACC process on the
prodigy so therefore we have less
contamination of other cells and cell
proliferation is more efficient of
course you can also do the density
gradient centrifugation manually but of
course for one for example 100
milliliter of bone marrow this really
takes long so closed and automated
system is quite advanced quite
advantageous here so other bio reactors
don't include the GGC process therefore
the starting culture cells contain many
other cells for example erythrocytes and
of course the proliferation is not very
efficient in this in this way so
furthermore the growth and the
detachment can be observed partly under
the microscope when we use prodigy
process therefore we have better control
of cell growth and harvest so other bio
reactors are not able to observe these
under the microscope for example when
you think about total fiber modules also
when you use a carrier system the
harvesting step is also always a little
bit tricky here
thank you the next one is is the ACCC
process also applied for umbilical cord
or adipose tissue
yes so it's possible to use the ACCC
process also with these be starting
material of course so the enzymatic
digestion of umbilical cord and also
adipose tissue has to be done manually
so this cannot be done within the
process but after you have your single
cells after enzymatic digestion you can
enter the prodigy process and also start
the the whole cuts of a cultivation
process thank you to what extent can the
ACC processes be automated
so when the liquid for example the media
or the buffer buffer is pumped out or
pumped into this deck you just need to
turn the stack so that the liquid can be
pumped out or evenly distributed in the
stack this takes only a few seconds
other than this the whole process is
done automatically so you can save
around around about 70% of hands-on time
compared to the manual system and also
the whole DGC process is completely done
automated so you can save a lot of time
here great as the prodigy system already
been used in any clinical studies or
cell therapy trials so the prodigy has
been used for several clinical trials in
the fields for graft engineering or 40
CRF a better system so a lot of things
have been done here and of course you
can find a lot of more information on
our website
thank you next one is does your MSC
expansion medium work well also with MSC
s from umbilical cord or adipose tissue
so the MSE bruge MP medium and also the
Stenmark 6f medium are can be used also
with umbilical cord or adipose tissue or
from starting material and also just to
expand the cells and there is also no
adaptation time necessary when you
switch between different cell culture
media okay next one is what markers to
you including your MSC phenotyping kit
so the MSC phenotyping kit includes CD
73 105 CD 90 they are the positive
marker and it's including a set of
negative marker which is CD 14 20 34 45
the cocktail does contain PE fits a PC
and Percy P and so it's possible to also
combine some other markers with a
cocktail for example it'll ADR so all
these markers in combination go in line
with the criteria defined by the ICT
consortium it looks like we have time
for one more question that will be can
you explain a bit more on how your MSC
immunosuppression inspector works yes
so the suppression inspector is a kid to
analyze immune model torque capacity of
MSS so the the reagent consists of CD 3
CD 2 cd28 coded particles which are used
to stimulate the T cells so the T cells
are previously labeled with a membrane
day and that means then after
stimulation the proliferated T cells can
be analyzed by a flow cytometry and here
the delusion of the membrane they can be
detected so when culture Co culturing
the T cells now with MSS in different
dilutions you can observe a reduced t
cell proliferation and this is what you
would like to see because this is the
effect of the immune modulator capacity
of emesis
I would like to once again thank
Catherine God Hertz for her presentation
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by this speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Milton biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
the laberd's will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye